at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking no question I must - any
organism endoskeleton
this episode is brought to you by all
form if you've been listening to this
podcast for a while you've probably
heard me talk about helix sleep and
their mattresses which I've been using
since 2017 I have two of them upstairs
from where I'm sitting at this moment
and now helix has gone beyond the
bedroom and started making sofas they
just launched a new company called all
form a LF ORM and they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door at a fraction of the
cost of traditional stores so I'm
sitting in my living room right now and
it's entirely all farm furniture I've
got two chairs I've got an ottoman and I
have an L sectional couch and I'll come
back to that you can pick your fabric
they're all spill stain and scratch
resistant the sofa color the color of
the legs the sofa size the shape to make
sure it's perfect for you in your home
also all form arrives in just three to
seven days and you can assemble it all
yourself in a few minutes no tools
needed I was quite astonished by how
modular and easy these things fit
together kind of like LEGO pieces
they've got armchairs love seats all the
way up to an eight seat sectional so
there's something for everyone you can
also start small and kind of build on
top of it if you wanted to get a smaller
couch and then build out on it which is
actually in a way what I did because I
can turn my L sectional couch into a
normal straight couch and then with a
separate ottoman in a matter of about
sixty seconds it's pretty rad so I
mentioned I have all these different
things in this room I used the natural
leg finish which is their lightest color
and I dig it I mean I've been using
these things hours and hours and hours
every single day so I am using what I am
sharing with you guys and if getting a
sofa without trying it in-store sounds
risky
you don't need to worry all form sofas
are delivered directly to your home with
fast free shipping and you get 100 days
to decide if you want to keep it that's
more than three months and if you don't
love it they'll pick it up for free and
give you a full refund your sofa frame
also has a
forever warranty that's literally
forever so check it out take a look
they've got all sorts of cool stuff to
choose from I was skeptical and actually
worked it worked much better than I
could have imagined and I'm very very
happy so to find your perfect sofa check
out all forum comm slash Tim that's al l
fo RM dot-com slash Tim all forum is
offering 20% off all orders to you my
dear listeners at all form comm / Tim
make sure you use the code Tim at
checkout
that's all form comm / Tim and use code
Tim at checkout this episode is brought
to you by LinkedIn jobs small businesses
have unique needs a lot of you know this
I know this and even with the
uncertainty these days one thing stands
unchanged and that is the importance of
having the right people on your team but
hiring can be hard it can be really
expensive if you make mistakes very
painful if you get it wrong I've
certainly had that experience and I'm
not eager to repeat it so I try to do as
much upfront screening as possible when
your business is ready to make the next
hire LinkedIn jobs can help you screen
candidates with the heart and soft
skills that you're looking for they'll
match your position with qualified
members so that you can find the right
person quickly using LinkedIn active
community of more than six hundred and
ninety million professionals worldwide
LinkedIn jobs can help you find and hire
the right person faster so when your
business is ready to make that next hire
find the right person with LinkedIn jobs
you can pay what you want and get the
first 50 dollars off
just visit linkedin.com slash tim again
that's linkedin.com slash tim to get $50
off your first job post terms and
conditions apply
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show I'm
thrilled to have today's guest joining
us Jan 11 on Twitter and Instagram at
Jan 11 that's jnn al e VI n is the Tao
professor of physics and astronomy at
Barnard College of Columbia University
and is contributed to an understanding
black holes the cosmology of extra
dimensions the gravitational waves in
the shape of space-time there's an end
in there and gravitational waves in the
space oh and the space of shape time you
know there are times the charm and
gravitational waves in the shape of
space-time you know that's not a
sentence I say very often she is also
director of Sciences at pioneer works a
cultural center dedicated to
experimentation education and production
across disciplines and pioneer works
virtual home the broadcast obviously
I'll link to all of this in the show
notes her books include how the universe
got its spots in a novel a madman dreams
of Turing machines which one the pen
Bingham prize she was recently named a
Guggenheim Fellow a grant awarded to
those quote who have demonstrated
exceptional capacity for productive
scholarship and quote her last book
black hole Blues and other songs from
outer space is the inside story on the
discovery of the century the sound of
space-time ringing from the collision of
two black holes over a billion years ago
and your timing of publication was just
incredible we might touch on that her
newest book black hole Survival Guide is
scheduled for publication at the end of
2020 Janna thank you so much for making
time to be on the show today I thanks so
much for having me and I have to say
hearing that bio it makes it sound like
it was smooth sailing which is what we
do when we edit our BIOS I would love to
have a bio that included all our
failures well the good news is that with
a long-form podcast we can fill in some
yeah and and talk about those and I
thought we would start way back in time
if we step into the time machine and not
necessarily with failures but I was
doing all sorts of homework for this and
I particularly enjoyed doing homework
for interviews when they involved my
friend
because I find all sorts of things that
I didn't know would you say that you
were reckless as a kid and do you
remember any particular notable
instances of getting in trouble oh my
god hilarious I'm so reckless it was so
reckless my parents used to say stop
diving off the high board without
checking if there's water in the pool
yeah I ain't had no health problems as a
child but yet I was in the hospital I
can't even mention how many times from
completely insane reckless accidents
breaking my nose it's okay my favorite
doing something crazy the worst was
skateboarding around I guess 11 and
hanging on to the back of a passing car
and hitting a break on the road and
landing on my head and experiencing
amnesia which is a pretty peculiar
experience and going into a coma so that
was a big but by far but it wasn't the
first or the last
I remember my father being he was so
devastated and and just can you please
stop you can't do this to us
and you've had some self-inflicted
wounds yeah and then you've had others
that you could certainly share more
details about but it like just like the
car accident could you describe this car
accident which I also didn't know about
yeah so I really am not known for being
risk-averse and so I guess it was mice I
was 16 to my 17th birthday night and I
didn't have a driver's license but
driving a friend driving a car and we
were really reckless and it was a storm
and we we wiped out and though in the
water the puddles hit some grass ended
up hitting kind of a footbridge
but flipping and landing upside down in
basically a canal and underwater and you
know
we all made it out alive which is pretty
amazing yeah scarred up you know I have
a scar on my face it was scar on my hand
it's not necessarily that noticeable but
it's definitely a mark and after that my
parents said you need to go to college I
was a junior in high school and they
said we can't take it anymore
we just we can't take it anymore you
need to go to college and I it was a
smart sort of instinct on their part
that I should do something more
constructive and I'll be less wild and
and I have old sisters older than me who
they've been through it before we're not
doing so it was by the summer of that
year when I was I didn't finish my
junior year because of the accident and
by the summer of that year I was
applying pleading with two colleges to
let me in and one of them had just
accepted women 4 in their curriculum was
an all-male school Columbia and its
sister school Barnard accepted me and so
two months later a little banged up I
started college it ended up saving my
life I'm sure of it hmm no did it save
your life it probably saved your parents
sanity by getting her out of the house
yeah how did it save you in the sense
that for many kids who go away to
college that is when they become
reckless right it was it offering a
larger challenge was it offering a the
type of coursework that you were
interested in it was all of it I was
still very interested in New York life
and New York was real rough around the
edges
and it was exciting and things I had
never seen before and subversive things
and all of that fascinated me but yeah
the actual scholarship was incredible
and that it wasn't a to switch situation
I was either a maniac or I was a scholar
like here
at this particular place I could be a
little bit of both in a better balance
and the scholarship here was absolutely
one of the most I mean for sure this
this incredible experience also being
that age your mind is voracious and
undisciplined but spongy and I loved the
intense intellectualism of this place
and paired with an absence of a
requirement to conform you know which is
a New York City thing or a feminist
college thing or you know Columbia
University thing and that combination
just I was extremely grateful also I
think because unlike maybe other
students who had gone through college
and the SATs and written all of their
essays and had the horrible experience
of being rejected and accepted like I
didn't have that I didn't have that
experience I was just pure gratitude
that they took me in two months after my
accident I was in college and I just I
really carried that feeling with me for
the years that just thank God thank God
it could have gone so bad what did you
think at that point when you're you're
walking into this incredible academic
institution off you go to college in
your mind what did you think you might
be when you grew up so to speak so it
never crossed my mind science being a
scientist never crossed my mind when I
started here I was really interested in
philosophy and I think in retrospect
what I was actually interested was the
big questions not you know not the
stylistic study of philosophy but the
questions but I didn't know that at the
time and loved literature I often say my
mother taught me to read and I don't
mean like sounding out phonetics as a
child I mean when I was 14 15 which is
the first time I actually started
reading realizer I mean I read for
school but my mom kind of taught me how
to read a book
and and I'm very strong memory Toni
Morrison's beloved was the first one
where she prepared me to slow down and
not to show off as a reader but to be
you know a receiver of this and to slow
down and to appreciate the depth of the
language and I absolutely my mother
taught me that and I remember that so
strongly discovering literature what did
the teaching look like was it suggesting
books to read and then discussing it
with her you didn't feel like teaching
at all it felt like sharing something
precious to her so I my mother's a
voracious reader I remember when I
realized we would have bookshelves and I
would pull the first book back and
realize they went three deep an
absolutely voracious reader and an
excellent reader like an intimate deep
perception of layers of stuff that and
what I learned also about that was that
you can write a book that not everyone
has to read at every level and it can be
wonderful and true yeah and maybe you
know not everybody wants it at that
level or they want others at that level
and not this one
oh that's fine you have to reach many
levels to have a truly great sculptural
construct and and that's what she showed
me and it was totally it wasn't at all
like sit you down I'm schooling you at
all it was very much just sharing like I
just read beloved you have got to read
this you will not believe what this what
Toni Morrison does in this book and it
was lots of things in a big range it was
Philip Roth it was Hemingway it was
whatever and so and when I when I
finally became a voracious reader I had
no quality control I just loved books I
would read crappy things I would read
wonderfully I would read classics like
there's no snobbery in it it was like oh
this one's just fun it was your Dom
Navarre yeah I became enough and so I
carried that with me and I
ever thought I was very intimidated by
everything I was very very intimidated
by all of it I didn't think I would have
what it takes to bring to be the
creative original in any of those
subjects I came in to be a student very
much so and philosophy within that
discipline if we want to call it
discipline in a system and rules for
sure rules and and you're you're asking
big questions what are the differences
between the answers that you get in
philosophy in the answers that you later
sought to get or studied historically in
science and then well certainly I want
to hear how on earth science came on
your radar yeah I mean that is spot on
the question spot on the question
because I enjoyed studying philosophy
but I was really frustrated with the
fact that and this is the example I
often use because it was really a
specific example in my experience what
Kant meant when he said it drove me
bananas know at the end of it infuriated
I was like if Kant who barely left his
home village sealed in his mind the
secrets of life I don't buy that
narrative that's not possible
it must not have been universally true
or he chose the wrong methodology for
conveying it and you know when which
we'll get to I think in this
conversation when Einstein exposed
special relativity what he discovered
nobody I swear to you nobody who studies
it is going back and saying what did
Einstein mean and that's an enormous
difference we don't become obsessed with
the cult of personality
with we are obsessed with the cult of
personality with Einstein but not to
extract the meaning of what he said
every eye can have erased from my mind
that Einstein existed as long as nobody
erases special relativity from my mind
and I can share it with anybody in the
universe that's a whole other level of
discovery and and transcendence and I
don't like things that whose truths are
rooted in a single man's mind or a
single cultural meme I want it to be
true in Bangladesh I want it to be in
true for me in New York I want it to be
true in another galaxy and that was the
shift for me what I realized that I
loved there were spending some time on
this because I studied some philosophy
as an undergrad had to and enjoyed it
because it's full of brain teasers and
it's prolly problem and all sorts of
things that are exciting and interesting
and difficult to explore and you have
this subjectivity of interpretation that
is really problematic and you mentioned
the transcendent right and for something
to transcend sérgio graphical boundaries
in a way it can't be bound to a
translation of a word from German to
English let's just say yeah because
you're you're arguing over what comp
meant but you're reading it in English
which is already an abstraction it's
like from what we would have read say
whether that's I mean that's true with a
lot philosophers so how does science
enter the picture so I mean personally I
mean for me like how did it happen yeah
for you history philosophy so what
happened and just to prep this we had
very rigorous science requirements which
I decided to get over with because I
didn't think I had any interest in
science and so my first year in college
like I went through chemistry and
organic chemistry and I did all those
super hardcore subjects and I remember
my chemistry professor are pulling me
aside and was like have you ever
considered physics
and I was like I but also because I
didn't finish high school I had never
had physics or calculus like I wasn't
that kid who had ap physics and calc I
didn't finish high school and so I was
offended
I was literally recoiled and I was like
physicists memorize equations and they
build bombs and there's no creativity
and like I was absolutely insulted and
and I was and I was also had to do
calculus as my math requirement and
there was a similar they were like and
we are considered doing some math I was
like oh gasp and then it really really
funny that that's not how it came
because what happen is as in a
philosophy class where we were arguing
about
Heidegger who is a philosopher whose
very contentious but who I really
enjoyed really enjoyed Heidegger but
more as a word played poetry you know
mind teaser then like admiration for the
individual which and there's a lot of
that in philosophy you know the hero
worship so anyways we're in I'm in this
class and this young guy comes in to do
his job interview to become a professor
at Columbia and he has a PhD in physics
his name is David Albert he's now a very
famous philosopher of science and he
comes in and he's not in my mind he's
doing philosophy at a totally different
way in style and he starts talking about
Einstein and free will and quantum
mechanics and determinism and everyone
even the most obnoxious show-offs in
those classes and I'm sure you know what
I mean or do everyone got quiet and I
thought wow I'm not hearing all the
bluster I usually here in this room and
I just was mesmerised and David Albert's
now a friend of mine and a colleague he
got the job
how do you spell his last name al BER T
like the first name okay
Albert Albert and he had no idea I was
sitting in the back of the room all
those years ago and I swear to you it's
what made me have that switch of I don't
want to talk about what comment nobody's
talking about what Einstein meant we
simply have to carry it on from where he
gave us the baton we can we have to keep
moving
that's the job the job isn't to obsess
about his personal life and its personal
psychology and the phrasing of every
word because math is universal and I had
this chilling experience that I cannot
even describe and after that I basically
switched I was probably a sophomore
going into my junior year and so by a
junior in college I switched my major to
astronomy and physics and I took math
going crazy which I always liked math I
always liked math I just didn't I just
didn't know I had any purpose for it and
so I scrambled I really scrambled to try
to catch up to my peers who were those
you know kids who had the chemistry set
in their basement and always knew and
knew things I didn't know and like had
intuitions I didn't have and so I really
scrambled and I think one of the reasons
why I became pretty mathematically
leaning was as a compensation for not
feeling like I had the intuition that
makes perfect sense
what did the chemistry and math teachers
see in you that led them to suggest
physics what did they Intuit or sense or
see or hear well I think you know the
math classes were very anonymous they
were big classes with calculus it was
very anonymous I just didn't really want
calculus I realized I liked math I was
good at it I didn't I didn't think twice
about it it's like being good at jump
rope I really didn't think twice about
it yeah I could crush the calculus and I
don't know why I didn't really have any
background it's not like something that
necess
runs in my family but I enjoy it
actually and I would find weird
solutions like they would throw one
problem on a calculus test that they
hadn't taught you how to solve and I
would like that problem and I wouldn't
spend my time on that problem and I
would fix it and I'm not saying I didn't
do badly sometimes but you know so
calculus was just sort of a skill thing
it was it was it really like jumping
rope and then with chemistry
I've always loved naturalism always and
I just didn't see it you know we talked
differently about it when I was a kid
nobody was like what do you mean by
naturalism nobody was like oh you're a
scientist
I loved books about evolution and I
loved it all Sagan and I loved lying on
the beach with my dad on a dark island
in South Carolina where there were no
streetlights like I'm a city kid I'd
never seen this guy and marveling over
the view of the Milky Way I just didn't
see it a science I saw it as an
experientially wonderful thing and I
loved my dad sir MD so where my mom
taught me how to read my dad taught me
how to ask questions no my dad's just a
super curious guy he would always talk
about why is it like this and why is it
like that
and just you know in a different 10
years later people would have said your
daughter's a scientist but at that time
nobody said that never crossed anyone's
mind and in retrospect I always had that
leaning I just felt it in a more kind of
organic poetic appreciation kind of a
way so we're gonna go deep we're gonna
go into all sorts of science before we
do I want to ask you for those who have
not delved into philosophy mm-hmm but
are interested in perhaps dipping their
toe in are there any particular favorite
philosophers you have for someone who
doesn't want to get stuck in the
quicksand of some of the philosophers I
shan't name but the gist
sort of semantic juggling that gets so
tiresome you have any favorite
philosophers to read that you would
recommend to folks it's tough I think
that you know somebody like Bertrand
Russell who's also a mathematician
Bertrand Russell is amazing I know this
is unpopular but I really enjoyed
Heidegger there was something to his
madness Vic and Stein for sure but
you're never gonna figure him out
the story of victory Stein's entire
family is fascinating and I have very
off a pinion about Vic and Stein but
that I still believe I think he was a
scientist and mathematician a mystic I
think he was a poet so I mean those for
me are the biggest standouts
I love the rationalists if you wanted to
study Locke berkeley hume take heart you
know all that's great but if you ask
like at a pleasure center level i would
kind of stick to Bertrand Russell
Heidegger and Vic and Stein and not to
miss the modern philosophers who are
basically very close to the boundary of
science and philosophy who are pushing
forward interpretations of quantum
mechanics understandings of the nature
of time and there's little communities
there's little centers like an Oxford at
Columbia at Rutgers I think there's one
at UCSC if I'm not mistaken where
they're really pushing physicists to not
be plumbers and to like you know like
not be like I got it I got a wrench I
know how to use it like to be like but
you don't understand that wrench let's
talk about it those people are really
really important and provocative and
nothing against plumbers Lenny Susskind
who is one of the most brilliant
physicists I've ever known was a plumber
and grew up in the Bronx a plumber son
and Lenny is one an absolute creative
genius in in theoretical physics amazing
and you mentioned the modern philosopher
so I don't know many
modern philosophers but is it the case
that with advancing technology and
discovery there is this reconnection or
convergence of philosophy and science in
very practical respects and one example
that comes to mind we don't have to
explore the specific example but I'm
wondering within physics and philosophy
or in the combination if this is true
you take something like the trolley
problem right so you're on a trolley
it's headed towards five workmen just
hypothetically and you can switch the
track and kill one person so you're
choosing between 105 but then there are
all these other considerations and with
autonomous driving you effectively have
to code in those types of decisions
right so this thought experiment in
philosophy 101 undergrad is all of a
sudden very relevant is that the case in
physics as well I would say that the
philosophers are doing the ones from my
perspective are doing the really
provocative important work are demanding
that physicists acknowledge that they
don't understand their most widely
accurately tested paradigm in the
history of science namely quantum
mechanics and so it's pretty wild that
we build these machines like the Large
Hadron Collider in Switzerland and that
we discover the Higgs particle the
goddamn particle which was appropriated
as the guard particle but the original
title was the goddamn particle and you
know is incredibly stunningly accurate
you can build stuff like for me that's
like the base level proof that
something's true and that we actually do
not understand it and I think that
they're right to press us that it's not
good enough just to build stuff that if
you technically philosophically
intellectually do not understand
something use it as a guide to tell you
what's beyond what more we could know
and I really think that the
Philosopher's on the interpretation of
quantum
the measurement problem which is to say
in quantum mechanics things don't always
assume a concrete state yet when we
measure them we find them only in a
concrete state like this kind of what is
reality stuff what is the role of
complex systems I think they're right to
press us on this and I think that
they're making way more progress than
the physicists are and you've spoken to
Sean Carroll and Sean in no small part
has made me you know look at that and as
a friend and as a colleague and as a
scientist he you know he has made me
look at that and I think he's right
about that and Sean and I actually have
a long-running joke because he was in
graduate school at Harvard when I was at
MIT we were very good friends and I
became more and more just calculate man
its objective reality just do it let's
just go
and he went more and more into
philosophy and we totally tease each
other about it all the time I'd love to
hear that like two glasses of wine each
end pasta salad how many how many how
many milligrams would you like Janna
let's dig into this maybe not directly
the what is reality that's a that's a
big one to bite off and also not my
favorite in a sense I do like the basic
pleasure of experience of something that
we've discovered of something you know
that we found on paper and math and then
it's out there I love that connect so I
think we can take that and use it to
stretch people who are listening a
little bit and that includes me I'm
gonna ask you a question that you've no
doubt been asked many many times and I
apologize I want to ask it anyway how is
it possible that the universe could be
finite it is the universe after all
right so I it's hard to just visualize
how that could make sense you should not
just be good eyes for that question
because it can it's ongoing
for me too so so Einstein had this funny
quote which I've said many times which
is only two things are infinite the
universe and human stupidity and then he
says and I'm not so sure about the
universe and as soon as Einstein started
talking about space-time and geometry so
basically seeing the universe as a
curved geometry his theory cannot
specify the global connectedness it's
not necessarily a shortcoming of
Einstein's theory of general relativity
it's just that we suspect that the
quantum theory of gravity beyond
Einstein will tell us something about
the global structure so for example if
I'm looking right now I have a teacup
and I'm looking at it super super
closely I see the curves on it
that's what Einstein taught us about but
if I put it further away I see a handle
and a connectedness of the handle and we
call that topology the fact that there's
a hole and that even if this was made of
clay there's nothing I could do to my
teacup to get rid of that hole unless I
broke it or did something like that so
we call that topology it has a feature
it has a feature called a hole it's not
equivalent to just a solid object and
that aspect of geometry once Einstein
said space-time is curved and it's
geometry people started to ask well what
about topology the connectedness so for
instance let's look at the earth you and
I are in different parts of the earth
maybe you're near a hill and you're
noticing the curves on the surface of
the earth you go up the hill you go down
the hill I live on Morningside Heights
by Columbia I go down a hill to Harlem I
go up a hill to Columbia and that's
local
but if I pan way way far back I see that
the earth is actually a sphere and I
don't see that up close and that is
something ridiculously enough we still
have flat earthers but that is something
that the Greeks and ancient astronomers
discovered it was not a known thing and
so that aspect of space-time that
compactness the fact that the earth
isn't infinite the earth isn't an
infinite plane it is actually curves
around wraps back on itself and is a
compact finite surface that was a
discovery recently in some sense Spanish
explorers were afraid that Columbus was
going to sail off the edge of the earth
that it was not compact and so this kind
of thinking should be we should be
asking that about the universe is it
possible so if I leave New York City and
I travel in a straight line as best I
can
I might need to pad all I manage to walk
I'm going to do it over I will come back
to New York City that was not known
until fairly recently and it might be
like that with the universe that if I
left the solar system in a spacecraft
and I left the galaxy and I traveled in
a straight line after a while I would
very surprisingly find myself coming
back to the Milky Way galaxy and the
solar system and does that infer this is
gonna be a third grade question I guess
they probably wouldn't use infer but in
my mind I'm imagining the universe as
this bubble that is spherical or oblong
or something like that if the universe
is expanding or contracting it can be an
extending finite surface
and then this sort of like wait a second
teacher question that I want to ask is
and I you see this coming right but if
it is finite what's on the outside of it
if that's even yeah
visually it's like sort of visual
espacially the the right way to think
about it I am NOT gonna deny that this
is hard for everybody even even very
accredited you know experienced
mathematicians this is not an easy
concept but I will tell you there is no
requirement for anything on the outside
there's this sort of Pat answer that
people give which is there's nothing
north of the North Pole go more north of
the North Pole and you go south I don't
love that answer because I understand
that intuitively people are saying yeah
but I could go up and and answer it's
it's not satisfying but here's what's
really hard to conceive of but I believe
I could convince you that's possible is
that I do not need to embed the
three-dimensional universe if it's
finite into a higher dimensional space
so let's talk about the earth the earth
as a surface forget about the inside
forget about it that it's a solid object
let's just look at the surface of the
earth that is two-dimensional all I need
to know on the surface of the earth is
east-west north-south 2d that's it yep
it lives in 3d though which is how as
three dimensional beings were able to
visualize it so we're like yeah the
earth is finite and it's 2d but there's
all this three-dimensional stuff that
it's lives in and we want to do the same
thing with the universe I want to tell
you there's a three dimensional
equivalent to the earth that is a sphere
it's a three dimensional sphere
you cannot visualize it and it need not
be nested in a higher dimension and
that's where you start to go like okay
and the the kind of impact of that is
that anything that space-time is part of
the universe
so if I said yeah we live in a higher
dimensional version of the earth a
three-dimensional sphere nested in a
higher dimension than any relativist
anybody who follows who uses einstein's
theory as a guide would say yeah but
that space-time and therefore that's
part of the universe so there is no such
thing as AZ space or time locations or
events that aren't part of the universe
all that would mean was that we
unnecessarily lived in four dimensions
so here's another example that I think
is going to make this a little bit more
manageable if you look at let's look at
pac-man which just turned 40 or
something right now now we're speaking
my language it just showed up on my
video feed you know how pac-man goes off
the right side of the frame and comes in
the left side of the frame yes and you
know how you can go at the top of the
frame and come in the bottom of the
frame yes
pac-man lives on a two-dimensional
doughnut that is not embedded in a
higher dimensional space that's it
there's no higher dimensional space
he lives enough to flats near
dimensional world so it is independent
mm-hmm so you mean by not no requirement
like in the video game rules he exits
the right side he enters the left side
he goes out the top he enters the bottom
I don't actually know if he can go at
the top or on the left or right side but
we'll extrapolate that means that
what topologists would call that is a
doughnut that it has the shape of a
doughnut he's continuously going around
in one direction and he can continuously
go around in the other direction but
that doughnut does not live in a higher
dimensional space it lives happily in 2d
on your 2d flat screen that's the whole
story mathematically he goes out one
side he comes in the other he goes at
the top he comes in the bottom and and
if you see that and you start to think
like okay wow that's a weird computer
rule but computer rules are only
reflecting mathematical rules and the
universe could obey the same rules I go
out to the right side of the universe I
come in the left side I go out the top
of the universe I come in the bottom
there is no need for that to live in
another space that's it I could do that
in three dimensions I could go forward
and come in the back and that's it it's
a three dimensional space it does not
live in a higher dimension it is just
connected in a mathematical way that
looks like a crazy doughnut if you
embedded it in a higher dimensional
space but it does not need to live in
the higher dimensional space any more
than your game pac-man looks like a
doughnut to you
so I islands if you want yeah
no I'm letting my neurons recover for a
second but I I think you could sell this
is this is where my head goes just to
just to show you how it just says so you
can lose any shred of respect you might
have for me thinking you could sell a
lot of t-shirts that would say that
donut does not it does not exist in a
higher dimensional space it's a donut
that doesn't live in a higher
dimensional space I mean there you go we
are limited by our experience were three
dimensional beings we understand that
the earth is a compact two-dimensional
surface that lives in a higher
three-dimensional space what we have
trouble with is the idea that there
could be a compact two-dimensional
surface that does not live in a hired
so the way that I've probably very
stupidly thought about this this is
speaking as a non-scientist non
physicist I never did take calculus
because I had a really I was actually
pretty good at math and I had a very
sort of abusive math teacher in software
your high school and I just said [ __ ] it
I'm out on cream though yeah my brother
had a great teacher and now he has a PhD
in statistics so it's not upset yeah
when I'm not upset my logic falls to
pieces no upset but but I try I listen
to just by way of analogy maybe
incorrectly as listening to an episode
of radio lab recently talking about
colors and the perception of colors and
what a rainbow would look like to a dog
say wow rainbow would like to a human
what it would look like to a butterfly
which has more range of colors it's
other rods or cones I always mix the two
but for color perception and then you
have something like a mantis shrimp
which has like 19 times the number of
these receptors compared to a human
right and you can try to describe what
it might look like to see a rainbow with
ultraviolet added but it's a real
stretch of the imagination to do so as a
human who has limited perceptual
abilities but then so it seems like to
me physics is sort of showing the
underlying code of the universe /
simulation that we live in and it's
allowing you to see the shape and form
perhaps of things that you cannot
perceive yeah as a human I don't know if
that's accurate but that's it's totally
accurate I would say that I discover
stuff through math that is so
counterintuitive that I really wrestle
with it which is why I love math because
it's telling me stuff that I can't see
hmm so even these things that I'm you
know blathering like I struggled with
them I struggled with these ideas
because we're really reliant on
intuition that we can see and perceive
curved surface in a higher dimensional
space or you know we can we always have
to go down and dimension the math I
follow and trust but believe me I cannot
visualize a three-dimensional sphere
nested in a higher dimension it's not
available to my mind or anybody else's
and and we can't do it and we can't we
don't have an intuition for it and so
that's where the math is this like
insane guide that we inherited that my
friend Brian Greene whom I don't know if
you've interviewed says things to me
like yeah maybe one day we won't do math
but right now it's all we got
[Laughter]
that's what it feels like the math shows
you something and you're like whoa so as
a here's an example of what math showed
me that I can't you know I can't
visualize so if suppose you had to
interact adrims in three dimensions okay
there's nothing you could do to separate
them to steel welded interconnected
rings loosely connected there's nothing
you can do to break them apart unless
you cut the steel right if you lived in
four dimensions spatially you could
actually lift them apart no problem I
say that one more time if you lived in
four dimensions you could take the steel
welded rings that are totally locked and
interconnected that could not be
separated without a chain saw in four
dimensions you can separate them without
breaking them and here's the here's the
analogy that helps with it
but it's still just you'll never be able
to see it I can't see it no
mathematician can see it either but in
two dimensions we can see it suppose I
had a big steel ring surrounding a small
steel ring in two dimensions and they
could never come off the plane they
could
ever come off the table there is nothing
I could do to get the small one outside
of the big one but cut the big one
yep yep you agree with that that's a
simple but if I live in three dimensions
I can simply lift the inner ring out
mm-hmm and yep
and that's what four dimensions allow
you to do with the interconnected links
and it's really hard to see that's wild
it's a wild it's a formal mathematical
proof just a quick thanks to our
sponsors and then we're right back to
the show first up LinkedIn jobs when
your business is ready to make the next
hire find the right person with LinkedIn
jobs using LinkedIn active community of
more than six hundred and ninety million
professionals worldwide LinkedIn jobs
can help you find the right person
faster you can pay what you want and get
the first fifty dollars off just visit
linkedin.com slash tim again that's
linkedin.com slash tim to get $50 off of
your first job post terms and conditions
apply second and last all form from the
creators of helix sleep all four makes
premium customizable sofas and chairs
shipped right to your door at a fraction
of the cost of traditional stores to
find your perfect sofa check out all
farm comm slash tim all form is offering
20% off all orders to you my dear
listeners at all form comm slash tim
that's all form al l fo RM comm slash
tim now i want to continue on this
journey down the rabbit hole you gave a
great talk via the moth called life on a
mobius strip why did you use the phrase
mobius strip so that talk it describes a
journey through life but one in which
you come back different
so really technically mathematically
different so if i take a left handed
glove and or let's start with a right
handed glove because most of us are
right-handed and i go around i travel
around a strip just literally imagine a
cylinder it comes back right handed
if you take that same glove on a trip
around a mobius strip which has a twist
in it you're right-handed glove comes
back left-handed and it is fundamentally
different yes and there's something in
the story that is related to that right
handedness which is very predominant in
nature and left handedness which is also
very predominant in different ways and
the idea that we take these things so
for granted we don't even question them
anymore why is your heart on the left
side of your body why is mine on the
left side of my body
what is the asymmetry that is for almost
every single person on the planet
there's an asymmetry that we all have
and it was kind of this story of strange
journey between me and my at the time
boyfriend now husband coming back with a
flipped chirality so left handedness and
right-handedness is known as chirality
going on a very peculiar journey and
coming back with a different chirality
like fundamentally different and I don't
know if you want me to do the spoiler of
the end of the story you know I think I
really want you to like I said I said
okay I suggest people listen to the talk
and we'll link to it in the show notes
but it's so my son his heart is on the
right side of his body and all of his
organs are mirror reversed and I the
fact that happened to me of all people
was pretty strange and and you know just
so people aren't alarmed the placement
of his organs are totally healthy
there's nothing wrong with having he's
literally a mirror image
of most of us and there's nothing
unhealthy about the organ placement
it's just extravagantly rare and it was
sort of I felt like it was this it's
also an incredibly rare genetic
condition you know my husband is an
Anglo Irish musician from an incredibly
tough brutal part of working-class
Manchester and you know I'm a sort of
like kid from Chicago who had everything
and it was like the odds of us both
having the resonance of that it's
extremely rare genetic condition and
going on this very peculiar journey
together and creating this exceptional
child who is a mirror image as though he
was taken on a trip around a mobius
strip and so that was the MA story and
we'll link to that everybody Tim Tim
that blog forward slash podcast and
you'll be able to find that Jenna
obviously and see all the links I wanted
to join me sorry to interrupt you two
but this is what we started with that
was something I was gonna tell nobody or
everybody and I told you nobody good I
mean I had some of my dearest lifelong
friends I didn't say a word about it and
I think the anxiety was that people
would find it so peculiar that they
would treat him as sickly and his organ
placement is healthy it's just
exceptionally strange and so we hid it
for years we just and and I think when I
told that monastery 2011-2012 maybe he
was 28 2011 yes he was 11 and by then we
felt so confident in his health and that
he would not perceive himself as sickly
and that other people wouldn't project
on him like if you tell that about a
chat about a baby
people become overly precious and it's
something I really don't like I really
don't like when kids are treated like
glass
and so it was this kind of dark secret
that Warren and I went to great lengths
to keep him healthy to see doctors to go
to zillions of experts to travel across
the country to have him participate in
studies but told none of our friends and
that was the till nobody or everybody
when the Mothe asked me to do it
I felt ready at about that point in time
to make it a work like a piece and work
on constructing it and work on the
levels of it as I would a book and even
though it was only a 15-minute story and
my son only heard it a couple of years
ago Oh No kidding yeah why and while
does these that's my that's my
exclamation of conversation it seems and
we cuz we didn't want him to be
overwrought about like we didn't want
him to feel sickly because we believed
he wouldn't be but it's a such a rare
condition I know not everyone does well
without condition it's so rare we got
off really lucky but it was really
important to us that he feel strong and
healthy and not have a consciousness of
a sick kid this is hell no one or
everybody and and you you followed that
we're talking before recording and I'm
paraphrasing here but it's either
silence or art right sometimes something
yeah those lying second and two
questions how did you feel after giving
the talk and then number two have you
taken other types of internal pressure
or angst or emotion and turned that into
art as a way of release or for other
reasons
I mean those are both I think really
valuable questions I do a lot of public
speaking about science and I have a I
have a pretty personal tone you know my
first book is pretty autobiographical
and personal and intimate so it's like
I'm afraid of that but I was terrified
of giving the mouth talk
it's so funny I'm onstage all the time I
don't get nervous like you could wake me
up in the middle of the night and I'd be
like yeah black holes but for this part
of it was that I was telling this story
for the first time that I had that I
kept to myself for over a decade and
part of it was that I was a exceptional
company it was the World Science
Festival and Eric Lander spoke about the
human genome project and using DNA
evidence to release prisoners who were
wrongly incarcerated huge Eric Landers
huge a guy who was doing hand transplant
surgeries for Marines and people in Iraq
like I was and then and it culminated
with a Nobel Prize winning Holocaust
surviving chemist no pressure me and and
they were like do you know talk about
your boyfriend an easy assignment
absolutely like oh my god a Holocaust
surviving Nobel prize-winning chemist
and I'm gonna talk about my boyfriend
really worked on that piece it was only
I only had a couple of weeks to do it
but it's one of the only times I can
remember having to walk around the city
block a couple of times to cool off I
begged them to let me go first cuz my
anxiety level was so high isn't but once
I got on stage I was like I'm in it I
got this yeah you were cool as a
cucumber so funny it just was it was
like a switch was thrown and I was like
I can do this
and to your second question oh it well
before me it's my second question
afterwards so you've finally shared this
secret with the entire
whole of men and womankind mm-hmm how
did you feel where you just with you but
you just blank were you elated were you
relieved what were you feeling it that I
think the hours post I think I was
elated because it didn't come out as oh
I'm revealing the pain in my heart it
came out to me and I don't know if
anyone else felt this way but it came
out to me as a sculpture that I worked
on and I felt really good about and that
I controlled my nerves and I got on
stage and when I get on stage and it's
good I feel like this it's because of
this like sort of love vibe from the
audience and the moth is such a
wonderful venue like they're so
fantastic and their audience just is on
your side and I I so felt that both from
Kathryn Burns the director who helped me
frame the story and and the audience
that that's why I locked into this
really other zone of feeling like I'm I
am telling a personal story to people I
care about even though I'm also telling
it to everybody and it just afterwards I
was elated yeah and you used the word
sculpture being proud of the sculpture
you made I mean you architected it right
you had the book ending of the chirality
it's it's well done I mean you put a lot
of time into it and effort it's very
clear I appreciate that and I do that in
writing like for me writing a sculpture
I have this weird relationship with
writing that it's sculpture I'm not
really sure how to explain it but it's
tell me more let's let's try it out well
I I feel like there were generations of
writers who really appreciated structure
and there are fads in writing then it
becomes there's a lot of self analysis
which is not structural and there's a
lot of different styles of writing and I
always really resonated with things that
had layers and I work really hard in
structure I lay out drawings on a board
and I work think really hard about
modules and elements and and I hope it
doesn't show right I don't want you to
read it that way but I want it to be
there and one of the conversations I had
with a friend recently was like he's
like Jana nobody's gonna notice that you
know one of our writers had a
grammatical error and I was like but
they will they might not they might not
quote the rule that he misused the
subjective tense but they'll feel it
they'll notice it in a really subtle way
and that's why great writers are
respected by tons of people who are not
great writers like I respect writers who
far exceed my abilities because I
recognize something that they're doing
not intellectually but emotionally it's
a felt sense it's a felt sense and and
so I feel that about structure if you
really really work on structure you
challenge yourself you break some bad
habits you don't allow yourself to be
self-indulgent and so yeah I really do
think of them like architectural II do
you have any particular writers who
stand out to you for structure oh man
I'm such a fiction fan I mean there's
this book I teach a class at the college
where I haven't taught it in a while
which is called science and literature
and it is basically a collection of
books that have all just seared me one
of them for instance is kutsu issue
Goudas never let me go and he won the
Nobel Prize a few years ago and that is
one of his least popular books and it's
spectacular it's about cloning and it's
a very personal intimate book how he
took this utterly abstract concept and
made it completely small and intimate
and it's stunning it's an incredible
book and he writes it in a female
first-person flawlessly it's just just I
mean it's just a it's partly a just a
display of unbelievable talent but it's
virtuosity thank you and but there's a
lot of books like that that I really
love there's an a book that's been
around for quite a long time Don
DeLillo's white noise which is also not
a one of his most famous books and is
hilarious and brilliant and incredible
and it's kind of about this small
college town professor and maybe a
chemical spill and you're not quite sure
what it is and it is absolutely
hilarious and incredibly clever I have
so many of these I'm not going to go
through all of them but I'm a LITTLEST
one more which is Cormac McCarthy's the
road which I don't think anybody would
look at as a science book it's a totally
apocalyptic book and I think people just
see it as an apocalyptic dystopia but
there is to me it's a science a
conceptual book but you know it has it
has that core and it's unlike any book
he's ever written in a lot of ways
because he can be a very kind of [ __ ]
Irian florid writer and this is Lena's
hell brutal and there's nowhere what who
went or how
no character has a name you don't know
where they are
whatever the apocalyptic event is it's
not named I mean it's just unbelievable
I read that book literally in cabs by
street light I read it in less than 24
hours I was possessed by it and my own
work the Turing machines book was
impressed at the same time that that I
was reading that book it was at the
press and we have the same editor from
Knopf Dan Frank who's just an
extraordinary editor and I called Dan
and he literally had to talk me off like
the window sill or just stop the presses
to present he literally talked me in
from the window sill so yeah I know that
feeling
and he didn't [ __ ] me he didn't be
like your book says gordas McCarthy he
was like look at him he's 77 look at
what he went through like he really gave
me respect to not treat me like a child
and and that's the only reason why I
came in back into the living room yeah
you knew you knew you were being
pandered it's not being right manhandled
her kid handled or whatever the
expression is have you read any of Ted
Chang's short stories thi ang I do you
know Ted Chang's short stories I believe
and this is maybe I should be
embarrassed to admit this I believe I
have a collection of short stories in my
audio book that I haven't gotten to I
highly recommend for people listening if
you want I think really structurally
interesting and also scientifically
mind-bending short stories Ted Chiang CH
ing his most recent collection is
exhalation which I thought could not
possibly equal his previous collection
and it maybe surpassed it
they're just so accountable and for
those people who saw a rival which is I
think an incredibly good movie yes
blurring the impact of language and
orthography meaning writing systems on
thought and how you perceive reality in
the context of alien contact right
extraterrestrial content that was based
on one of his short stories and it's
he's really got incredible range right I
mean should I be kind of ahzab or hazy
in like vision you know the [ __ ] has
like yep but I think what you're
pointing to so a lot of people ask me
about sci-fi and I'm not a rabid sci-fi
fan I enjoy it but that's not I think
the reason why I select the authors I
select is because they don't usually
write about science and when they turn
to it they turn to it with the care like
Chang the care and emotion and intimacy
that they would - absolutely any other
subject totally agree and I have to ask
if you have read any of just say that I
I recommend to people listening if they
haven't if they're interested in this
type of nerdy writing structure
exploration which i think is more
broadly speaking an exploration of
thought and structured thought that
draft number four by John McPhee
is definitely worth oh it's it's worth
to read it's very nerdy it's based on a
seminar that I don't believe he teaches
anymore at Princeton called the
literature effect and I'm a little
obsessed with John McPhee I've always
had this terrifying fantasy / nightmare
that he would this is about to get good
he would like read one
my pieces and critique it yeah yeah he
is uh he's one of those writers were
like I just don't I can't do this yes
technical finesse and and prowess and
skill is something that I really do
admire and it's what we were talking
about you don't have to have that skill
to recognize the skill and and to
experience the pleasure of the gift of
somebody giving that to you and you know
he's known as a terror when he edits
people so I do have just an anecdote
related to editing so I took his seminar
I did what I wish had happened to me
back then so you have to go through such
a grueling process of unlearning bad
writing well I have been look I'm not
I'm no McPhee but I remember the first
assignments we were handed back with
feedback and in effect he said before I
hand this out I want you all to realize
that you're good writers and I'm
paraphrasing of course and you were able
to get into this seminar and we'll
discuss everything and your one on one
so we had one group class I think it was
12 students per week and then one-on-one
time with him and he's an incredibly
good teacher and the pieces were
generally of a short length let's just
say the assignments were three pages I'm
just gonna make that up three pages long
I still have my three-ring binder with
all my notes from that long time ago 20
plus years ago and there was more red
ink on my essay than black ink meaning I
had typed out three pages and
double-spaced and his comments seemed to
be more than my cumulative ink on the
page and I was just like holy [ __ ] I'm
in trouble like this is good and not
again
what a gift and one thing that this this
will really underscore the reason I
recommend people read good books and
even consider studying writing is that
you get better at thinking so he pulled
out so much fat and just useless drivel
trim and redundancy from my writing that
my grades in all of my other classes had
a sharp uptick Wow and his class took up
a lot of energy so it wasn't that had
extra slack in the system I think it was
because my thinking became tighter and
for people who really want a wonderful
book to read that is pretty short I
don't know how long it is maybe it's 200
pages John McPhee wrote a book called
levels of the game and if you want an
idea of how structure what would it
means to structure a book in a really
elegant interesting way this is a book
that is structured around his
description of the semi final match at
the 1968 US Open Championship between
Clark Graebner I think it is an Arthur
Ashe so this is this is an entire book
based on ostensibly one tennis match but
that's the that's the framework and that
the way that you then manipulates that
and architects it is just incredible and
I'm not a tennis player so it tells you
a lot I just gripped so this is one of
those books like you and I rode that I
just carry it around and I read it every
every open moment mm-hmm to finish
that's a recommendation so the other
person who broke my heart when he died
was David Foster Wallace mm-hmm who can
write about things I have exactly zero
interest in and gripped me the Illinois
State Fair consider the lobster consider
the lobs what do I care about lobsters
in Maine and not my world the Oxford
English Dictionary and every one of
those essays
is loaded with unbelievable insights and
you know I I don't know if he ever
studied with John McPhee I don't think
he did but but I sort of think of him as
sort of the wild maverick version of
John McPhee oh definitely the wilder and
a completely different person but my
other story about John McPhee is I did a
talk at Princeton a couple years ago
like a panel talked about writing with
some colleagues and I'm not gonna name
the person who said this to me but he's
a very accomplished writer any study
with John McPhee as you did and he said
that as a grown man accomplished you
know writer in everywhere major made his
career went back to John shared one of
his pieces with him and John liked
edited he said he was in tears he and he
was you know and yet everything was on
the nose John you're like now that know
if people don't want to read an entire
book like draft number four about
writing there is a series of interviews
that John McPhee for those people
wondering how it's spelled MC pH EE did
with the Harris revue in a series they
do called the art of nonfiction so if
you search the art of nonfiction John
McPhee I may have actually put it on my
blog I think I got permission to
republish it because it was so good yeah
so people can look for that he's the
virtuoso of nonfiction yeah you really
remarkable this is gonna be a total left
turn but that's but I'm gonna go left
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna go
back to thoughts of chirality is
directly related to chirality
necessarily but I texted use not too
long ago and I'm embarrassed to say that
I haven't actually made much headway
because I be a man
enamored of a separate novel called
little big that I we could talk about
another time I can okay for hours about
it but I texted you about Carl
rovelli yeah yeah and specifically
because I was looking at a book he wrote
about time and our misconception Travon
brief lessons it was a different one it
was a different one yes seven brief
lessons there's another I think it's
called the order of time something like
that yeah and I have it I'm planning on
reading it so this isn't a question
about Carlos specifically it's it's
about time and I'm wondering if there
are any because humans experience time
as this linear progression right or sans
falling to the bottom of the hourglass
in this finite life that we have but how
do you think about time or what are
certain realizations or conclusions
about time that might seem very strange
or counterintuitive yeah so let's start
in the concrete the things that we know
are true there are forms of time travel
that we absolutely know are possible I
can travel to the forward of your time I
can't travel to the fort of mine but I
can travel to the forward of yours
so for instance if I decide to travel
near the speed of light to go to
Andromeda a nearby galaxy and come back
traveling very near the speed of light
I might have experienced as close as I
get to the speed of light I will
experience his little passage of time as
imaginable but let's just say it's a few
months for me for you gosh Andromeda is
2.5 million light years away it would
have two point five million years would
have passed so shame to say despite all
of your fantastic protein powders that I
would come back to the grief of not
finding you here and not America and
maybe not any human beings maybe human
beings would be extinct and so I can
travel to the forward of your time but I
I haven't yet figured out how to travel
to the fort of mine to me I would have
had a few months
my clock would have tipped slowly my
milk would have lasted as long as I
expected my thoughts would process on
the timescale I'm comfortable with I
would not notice anything but ordinary
time and and that's a fact
that that is true we experimentally
measure that we experimentally detect
that we know that that's a fact after
that fact which is pretty big to take on
its own if you want to like for instance
we could travel 26,000 light-years to
the black hole at the center of our
galaxy as long as we went very very
close to the speed of light we would
survive the trip but 26,000 years would
have passed on earth and so what's so
great about that yes is the interstellar
dilemma
it's the interstellar dilemma
interstellar actually got that really
right and I actually want to mention
interstellar because Kip Thorne I have a
lot of connections with this because Kip
Thorne who is one of the most creative
physicists I've ever known
wrote the treatment for interstellar it
was his idea to write that it was his
treatment he also won the Nobel Prize
for the LIGO experiment which detected
the collision of black holes and he was
also one of the two main characters in
the book that I wrote about the
discovery so Kip and I have tons of
connections and also I consider him a
wonderful friend and he was one of the
only people when I was completely
unknown and kind of waffling and nobody
liked my work I was working on stuff
that nobody respected or thought was
good he was the only person who pulled
me into his office and said I am really
curious about what you're doing this is
odd and interesting and I was a nobody
and so so Kip looms large in my life in
a lot of ways and therefore interstellar
also the moth story that we talked about
I've sold the film rights to that with
Linda opes and Nick Wechsler attached
who are the Linda is the same person who
produced who helped Kip make
interstellar so there's small world is a
big suit Nobel Prizes and black holes to
Hollywood amazing yeah I mean kit said
to me at 80 he said you know I'm gonna
start this new career and at making
movies the coolest coolest most
wonderful guy I mean I I cannot sing
Kipps praises enough I'd have to get Kip
on the podcast Sunday oh you must and
he's so clever and kind and thoughtful I
mean he's really an exceptional one of
those walks the earth every 50 years
maybe you know I'm sold
yeah and I don't want to take us off you
said fact number one that's big enough
to sort of wrap your head around yeah
we're talking about time yeah what else
do we so the tough stuff the stuff that
we don't know as fact that we're
grappling with that we don't have the
full picture over is what is time why
does it insist on having a different
role in space
I mean Einstein taught us that there's
space time and you know I'm adamant not
to put a hyphen in that it's space time
it's a one phenomenon we live in four
dimensions to talk to you Tim I have to
specify three in person three spatial
coordinates where we are north south
east west
what floor were on up and down and what
time were at and it is absolutely clear
that that space and time are kind of
this unified thing yet time is viciously
different it refuses to conform I can
turn left and right but I can't turn
forward and backward in time why not and
the laws of physics even more so are
completely invariant under the direction
of time meaning if I showed you a movie
of a billiard balls knocking the reverse
movie would make equal sense but if I go
up complexity levels and I show you a
flower
or a flower rotting you immediately know
which ones forward and backward but the
laws of physics don't have that in them
how why is that so we really if I showed
you a movie forward and backward that
was complex enough you could tell the
difference but if it was basic enough
you couldn't and there's something about
the laws of physics that they're
basically totally reversible you
shouldn't be able to tell the difference
between forward and backward and yet
relentlessly we go forward and so this
is the crux of some deep mystery that we
haven't solved and there are very smart
ideas about we can get partway in the
conversation about entropy and all that
crap but something about time is
resistant to interpretation and and
understanding I'm on it consider me on
the job Carol has written a wonderful
book called from eternity to here which
lays these dishes out and I think is
really a really nice read check it out
I'll link to that as well it makes me
think of what a friend of mine said to
me at one point during kovat when
there's still I mean there's so much
uncertainty but at the time it was all
uncertainty and he said I think it's
time to take some peyote and talk to the
Pangolin maybe there's something to be
said for discerning discerning the
subtleties of time it's not that
different from like Roger Penrose to
Roger Penrose who's an absolute I don't
know national treasure for for England
he describes that moment of having a
realization on one side of a street that
he's crossing forgetting it while he's
going through the complex process of not
getting hit by a car and getting
together sided Street and feeling elated
but not remembering the thought
and to recover the thought and I think
that that's something in a sense that
we're skirting around when we're talking
about film and storytelling and the
structure of books and art is that
sometimes we need those other fertile
grounds even if it confuses us for a
second even if we remember the direct
aid to be logic of the thought that
becomes a kind of a fertile ground for
when we recover that thought for it to
actually be able to implant in a bigger
way or something I don't want to over
push metaphors but I do you're in good
company for that sometimes when you lose
your train of thought when you come back
to it you found a better way to boost it
and expand I have a question for you
that I don't think she would mind which
was was solicited from by yours truly
our mutual friend Maria Popova picking
sorg everyone should check that out if
you don't know what I'm talking about
one of the most prolific how makers and
writers and consumers of information you
want to talk about wanting to hang up
your Spurs yeah English is not even her
native language I mean it's just I don't
get it
I mean oh my god it's really like
sometimes I'm just like okay I give up
yeah I give up amazing and she's part of
what I mean it's true she's Bulgarian
English it's not her first language she
has the lightest lightest accent but her
command of English is beyond basically
anyone elses yeah it's outrageous it's
really yeah it's really something else
it's this was I was texting with her
asking about any topics or questions
that she thought could be fertile to
explore and and and this is one of the
things that she sent me
you might want to ask her about the
tension I think mostly a creative
tension but sometimes a troubling human
tension between living with a mind that
deals with such vast and remote skills
with space and time she jokes that she
isn't interested in anything that took
place less than 500 billion years ago
back with with so much abstract
mathematics which is what theoretical
physics is yet living in a body more to
the here and now to the human political
and biological realities that we're
living with number one I just want to
point out this is a casual text for
[ __ ] sake I mean I just want to give a
good tire but but but this is this is a
question I'd love to explore because one
of the things that you alluded to in
your mouth talk was that thinking of
these vast scales and periods of time in
some way make your day-to-day grievances
and problems seem very trivial right or
put them in perspective so could you
speak to that to the tension between
this vast macro longitudinal picture and
then the day-to-day yeah I can but it's
not such an easy package I mean I am
absolutely as vulnerable to anybody else
to the stress of quarantine not grooming
oneself my hair is wild not socialising
and missing your friend like that
doesn't it doesn't it's not a panacea it
doesn't it doesn't make me not miss
those things or not struggle with those
things but in the bigger scale I think
feeling of freedom from the requirement
to conform and you know some of the
pressures of social media it has helped
me in those ways there's no question
that having more universal perspective
put
those things into their tiny packages
where they belong has been you know
easier for me and Maria is absolutely
right I used to call it local politics
anything that happened more recently
than about a million years ago is local
politics and I take very little interest
in it I don't get worked up about stuff
that's happening on the earth and but
then again I do I got totally swept up
in the recent events and rightfully it
because I think if you have even a
modest platform you have to speak out
like these aren't things I want to do
I've no interest in politics I have no
interest in identity I don't see having
more melanin or having this genitalia or
having this psychology like it's zero
interest to me frankly but I see it as
hurting people close to me and so I'll
speak out and do those things but yeah I
find solace in a very far horizon view
understanding even though I'm kind of a
brutal atheist understanding having a
sense of meaning and connectedness to
the universe because I realize we are
progeny of this universe we are direct
descendants of the Big Bang we are
direct descendants of the generation of
stars that made carbon and oxygen we are
direct descendants of neutron stars
colliding and providing us with gold
which is actually this insane monetary
thing that we exchange with no
understanding that the absolute only
place that came from was the collision
of two dead stars somewhere else in the
universe that's through it our way that
give me such a good warm fuzzy sense
meaning that I don't need to turn to
fairies and fantasies you can leave that
to me
I'll take that very but you know that's
why I love it
that's why I love it it doesn't there
used to be this and I think it's fading
but that's kind of 1950s attitude
murdering to dissect I mean most
scientists are looking for meaning and
Brian Greene's recent book is all about
search for meaning and he's a brutal
naturalist and as I am and and it's
about meaning and so I think that that
shift is starting to happen in the
cultural consciousness that scientists
aren't bout destroying emotion they're
about finding a different way of feeling
connected to the world I like that that
rings true to me and let's use this as a
segue to an answer that you provided
very graciously in my last book tribal
Mentors I asked a question in the last
five years what a new belief behavior or
habit has most improved your life so I'm
just gonna read this then we'll dive
into it so these are your words I used
to present obstacles along the path
thinking if only that hadn't happened
life would be so good then I suddenly
realized life is the obstacles there is
no underlying path our role here is to
get better at navigating those obstacles
I strive to find calm measured responses
to see hindrances as a chance to
problem-solve often I fall back into old
frustrations but if I remind myself this
is a chance to step up
I can reframe conflicts as a chance to
experiment with solutions what led to
this realization oh man it is one of my
one of my best you know how we mate we
might all have these certain folders we
nail into the wall to cling to this is
one of them for me very much so I think
we struggle with the idea of who's
privileged and who's not privileged what
opportunities have you been given what
have you earned and we all
have a different balance of that I
definitely had feminist parents you know
I had intellectual parents I had a lot
of ups and advantages and when I came to
blocks in the road I really didn't like
that I had people to send up on me and
demand what do you have to say about
being a woman in science like it really
bugged me and I thought but you're not
talking about all these leg ups I had
from all these other people and how I
look around and I don't see any you know
a lot of diversity
why should I only talk about the
hardship in my road like it bugged me
instinctively
and I think that what I realized was I
had been sold because of my kind of
comfy childhood an idea that life is
great and just don't screw it up and
that's false life is not great for most
people and they have to do a hell of a
lot more than not screw it up they have
to build bridges and pave ways and do
things no one's ever thought of and
fight poverty in and find solutions and
I just thought my the people that have
taught me the most have done those
things and that we have to stop
fantasizing that were you know my dad
always said you know my dad was from a
you know tougher upbringing and he
always said life isn't fair he told me
that all the time oh my god it's so
hilarious I can totally hear him saying
it life's not fair it's not about
fairness nobody told you you were owed
fairness no such thing and it really it
really taught me to think that Oh
life is a series of obstacles it's not a
paved path and
the obstacles are what make you and you
know when I've really screwed up with
something like that I felt really deep
shame nobody had to tell me to be
ashamed I felt really ashamed
and when I've succeeded in that I felt
really good and nobody needed to tell me
I should feel good about it it's just
obvious and so I started to see life as
a series of obstacles that were tests
trials you know teaching modules of how
to be a better person and to pave the
way behind you not in front of you and
it's really been a pretty important
principle for me I guess that when I see
something happen I don't think this is
so unfair
why are they doing this to me that I
think instead okay am I able to rise to
figure out a solution to this and I'm
not always able to do that you know but
when I do I feel like it's genuine
progress well sin it's an enabling lens
of agency right yeah we talked about a
little bit before recording but I mean
there's certainly you are wherever you
are in some people certainly much more
than others you're going to run into
boots in the face yeah and then the
question is what do you do when you run
into a boot in the face and yeah I think
it's very interesting that certain
people with privilege are enraged by a
boot in the face because they were told
that they had the road paved ahead of
them and it's an advantage to not think
that so that when the boot is in your
face your immediate reaction isn't like
how dare you I deserve this I'm owed
this opportunity that your reaction is
instead oh that's who you are you're the
guy with the boo
and what can I do to go around you what
can I do to go over your head and to be
okay with that I think a lot of us cling
to the degrees and the accolades and
trust me it's you know help me and my
wife to have those things so I'm not
just missing them and I'm really
grateful for them but if you're not
gonna get that accolade big deal learn
how to pivot move away from the boot the
boot actually has no power unless you
insist on continually pushing against it
unless you consider it your only Avenue
forward and you're just gonna keep
pushing until the boot and convince the
boot and you know that forget it
move to the left and figure out
something else and go over their heads
and that's really really liberating that
took me much longer to realize and it's
super liberating suddenly you know
they've got no power over you if you're
not interested in the avenue that they
offer
I loved your answer in the book and I
love your explanation you know life is
the obstacles there is no underlying
path it's actually very relieving mhmmm
in a way and it makes you less resentful
like whatever this happen to me and this
is so unfair no it's not it's an
opportunity to develop your yourself you
know it's exciting and your recklessness
of you're back in your childhood I think
has remained with you and not being
least as far as I can tell terribly
risk-averse you try a lot of new things
yeah you seem to have started in a sense
your mother teaching you how to deeply
absorb and read books to look at the
lines but look between the lines and
really pay attention so you are a woman
of words or a girl of words and you
became a woman of numbers and some years
ago you started doing poetry readings
and some of them have been incredibly
popular so you found your way back
towards not that you ever completely
left obviously you've done a lot of
writing and I'd love to just explore
this through the example of one and that
is a brave and startling truth this is
from the 2018 universe inverse this is a
poetry reading that has gone effectively
viral I think as far as things go viral
as far as such things go viral why
poetry reading and why this particular
poem well I want to be totally clear
about this I am a prose writer
I have zero foray into poetry
I like poetic prose but I like prose
it was absolutely my friendship with
Maria and Maria and I both were kids who
said things like I don't like poetry or
I'm not interested in poetry and Maria
has written today yeah this wonderful
story that she tells about her friend
Emily Levine who's a petite older woman
who slapped her hands on the coffee
table in the coffee shop they were in
stood herself up and began reciting
poetry as an act of outrage that Maria
said she wasn't interested in pressure
that's the right approach with Maria
that sounds like a good path obviously
now Maria is the ambassador she runs the
single most popular poetry series in the
country the world really and it came out
of our collaboration it's about the
universe but it's absolutely a hundred
percent Maria and so she similarly
forced me him in a less public way than
Emily Levine did to her but forced me to
start to look deeper into poetry and and
so as a brilliant curator which is
really what Maria is she's a brilliant
essayist and curator and she's a
brilliant reader she found poems for me
and
curated them for me and a brave and
startling truth was like the the thing
about that one was like I kept crying
every time I read it at a home and I was
like I will not go up on stage and cry
during this poem I'm not gonna do it and
there are like opera singers who
describe these with certain areas that
they can't do them because they break
down sobbing so I had to practice it
enough that I could control my impulse
like to break out into tears it is such
a stunning piece of work it's not only
Maya Angelou at her best but she had
this fantasy about thinking about space
and the poem actually flew to space it
was it went onto one of the NASA
missions and went to space and it's like
what we're talking about structurally
and all these levels it has all these
levels the relationship with Maria the
friendship with Emily Levine the lake
Maya Angelou that flew to space on NASA
and I finally rehearsed it so that I
only choked up a little bit what was it
that choked you up and I mean it's a
beautiful poem I encourage everybody to
listen to it or read it certainly and
and I'll link to everything but what was
it was there one thing about it or an
eight-speaker aspect no exactly a good
question because it's not one thing it's
the build-up it's the build-up it's the
layers we are not Devils or Divine's
it's not maudlin or saccharine she
describes our ugliness as human beings
and and then says I mean basically the
essence of the concept of the brave and
startling truth is that we realized that
it's us and she doesn't do it in a
saccharine or sentimental way she
describes us as Devils and the ugliness
of the human spirit to build up to that
kind of Epiphany
that when we go out into space it's like
Earthrise you know the picture of the
Earth rising above the lunar surface
taking taken by one of the Apollo
missions we are out there in space and
then we turn around and we look at
ourselves and it's just angela's salt of
the earth despite all odds belief in the
human spirit yeah it's it's a wonderful
piece and you are so fun to talk to
I also have fun in person which not
everybody knows I said it's true we
overlap here and there sometimes on
purpose sometimes by accident but it's
always such a pleasure yeah I'm so
thrilled that you were able to make the
time to have a have a chat it gave me an
excuse to grill a friend and do all this
homework I really really enjoy it just
it provides so many extra layers as
we've been saying about many things and
is there anything else you'd like to
share or mention that I haven't well
just I've been trying to get you you've
been out to Pioneer works but I would
love to have you out on our stage and
whenever you know the modern plague
allows we really want to have you come
join our sort of community of oddballs
and artists and musicians and and be on
the broadcast and you know so I'll be
pursuing you man I'd love to do it I
mean I would love to do it
pandemic to do something with you in
June tented worthy and you know I think
we'll make then The Book of Revelations
started yeah
I'm pretty sure her guests are nexts
there happen in Africa literally there's
a yeah I know
plague it's banana yep maybe we'll have
this my friend says the alien invasion
or okay I have to I have to bring this
up because you mentioned aliens are you
aware that the government during the
pandemic effectively said yep there are
aliens or there are UFOs and here's a
bunch of footage from a military and it
went without effectively without any
commentary it's like oh yeah no we've
known about UFOs they're a real thing
here's some footage and it just went by
like nothing else but I admit I haven't
done the study me to like you know suss
out legitimacy yeah I haven't done any
forensic analysis and his friends their
bosses but if you people can do their
own searching if you if you search
military footage yeah UFOs and that does
not mean aliens right we've read that
same is but unidentified flying objects
yeah maybe we're in a video game that's
all I'm saying I feel like because you
know I'm a big believer that life in the
universe is it's impossible that were
the only ones but I have very cynical
ideas that they have the same technology
that they live right now that you know
we've been around for a bleep they're
not here at the same time like right
next door like I have a lot of cynicism
about that kind of stuff but I'm very
very open to the idea that there's life
in the universe well I think I think
that deserves a bottle or two of one
yeah once again yeah pandemic allowing
and Jenna you're so much fun people
should definitely check you out wherever
they can at Jan 11 on Twitter and
Instagram Jan 11 calm your books are
incredible you're an excellent writer
and you have a new book coming out in
the not-too-distant future black hole
Survival Guide scheduled for publication
at the end of 2020 we shall see
so TBD gonna be a tiny little thing like
a pussing you should put in your back
pocket it's gonna be like an object more
than like a thick book
I like that I mean it's Lea Halloran the
artist Lea Halloran did these like
gorgeous paintings for it so it's gonna
be really like an object can't wait to
see it
I can't wait and we are recording this
on a Friday and I want to let you get to
your weekend mentioning wine has got me
thinking about some wine and once again
thanks for making the time this has been
so much fun thanks to him such a
pleasure miss you I miss you too and to
everybody listening thank you for tuning
in and we will link to everything all of
the things that we brought up we'll have
links to them in the show notes as usual
just go to Tim dot blog forward slash
podcast or you just go to Tim that blog
really and search Jana J&N a and it all
popped right up and until next time
thanks for tuning in hey guys this is
Tim again just a few more things before
you take off number one this is five
bullet Friday do you want to get a short
email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday the event provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that have somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour work week
come that's four hour work week calm all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
LinkedIn jobs small businesses have
unique needs a lot of you know this I
know this and even with the uncertainty
these days one thing stands unchanged
and that is the importance of having the
right people on your team the hiring can
be hard it can be really expensive if
you make mistakes very painful to get it
wrong I've certainly had that experience
I'm not eager to repeat it so I try to
do as much upfront screening as possible
when your business is ready to make the
next hire LinkedIn jobs can help you
screen candidates with the heart and
soft skills that you're looking for
they'll match your position with
qualified members so you can find the
right person quickly using linkedin's
active community of more than six
hundred and ninety million professionals
worldwide LinkedIn jobs can help you
find and hire the right person faster so
when your business is ready to make that
next hire find the right person with
LinkedIn jobs you can pay what you want
and get the first $50 off
just visit linkedin.com slash tim again
that's linkedin.com slash Tim to get $50
off your first job post terms and
conditions apply this episode is brought
to you by all form
if you've been listening to this podcast
for a while you've probably heard me
talk about helix sleep and their
mattresses which I've been using since
2017 I have two of them upstairs from
where I'm sitting at this moment and now
helix has gone beyond the bedroom and
started making sofas they just launched
a new company called all form a LF ORM
and they're making premium customizable
sofas and chairs shipped right to your
door at a fraction of the cost of
traditional stores so I'm sitting in my
living room right now and it's entirely
all farm furniture I've got two chairs
I've got ottoman and I have an L
sectional couch I'll come back to that
you can pick your fabric they're all
spill stain and scratch resistant the
sofa color color the legs the sofa size
shape to make sure it's perfect for you
in your home also all foam arrives in
just three to seven days and you can
assemble it all yourself in a few
minutes no tools needed I was quite
astonished by how modular and easy these
things fit together kind of like LEGO
pieces
they've got armchairs love seats all the
way up to an eight C sectional so
there's something for everyone you can
also start small and kind of build
top of it if you wanted to get a smaller
couch and then built out on it which is
actually in a way what I did because I
can turn my L sectional couch into a
normal straight couch and then with a
separate ottoman in a matter of about 60
seconds it's pretty rad
so I mentioned I have all these
different things in this room I used the
natural light finish which is their
lightest color and I dig it and I've
been using these things hours and hours
and hours every single day so I am using
what I am sharing with you guys and if
getting a sofa without trying it in
store sells risky you don't need to
worry all form sofas are delivered
directly to your home with fast free
shipping and you get 100 days to decide
if you want to keep it that's more than
three months and if you don't love it
they'll pick it up for free and give you
a full refund your sofa frame also has a
forever warranty that's literally
forever so check it out take a look
they've got all sorts of cool stuff to
choose from I was skeptical and it
actually worked it worked much better
than I could have imagined and I'm very
very happy so to find your perfect sofa
check out all forum comm / Tim that's al
l fo RM dot-com / Tim all forum is
offering 20% off all orders to you my
dear listeners at all form comm / Tim
make sure you to use the code Tim at
checkout that's all form comm / Tim and
use code Tim at checkout
you
you
you
you